una buena parte del libro de piketty
trata sobre esta idea de que un
rendimiento de capital que aumenta más
rápido que el crecimiento de la economía
y donde vemos gráficas como esta donde
está el valor del capital privado como
porcentaje del ingreso vemos esta
dinámica en varias de las gráficas donde
está aquí la edad dorada y se llega a
este pico local y al entrar al siglo 20
vemos esta caída y luego vemos que sigue
aumentando hasta la fecha actual que es
este punto en los datos después están
las predicciones de piketty en donde se
muestra la idea de que el rendimiento
del capital aumenta más rápido que se
una cosa que debemos pensar es el por
qué podría darse esta dinámica y con
esto podríamos basarnos en lo que
nosotros pensamos que podrían ser las
proyecciones pensamos las posibles
razones por las que el valor del capital
privado podrían disminuir y las razones
por las que este valor podría aumentar
una razón es que imaginemos que tenemos
un
fui y lo compré en un mercado así que el
valor actual de este bien el valor hoy
es de 100 dólares y digamos que esté
bien nos da un ingreso de 10 dólares
así que para este bien tendremos un
rendimiento r del 10 por ciento recibo
10 dólares por cada 100 dólares de
inversión existen varias razones por las
que este valor podría aumentar una razón
es que este bien podría generar un mayor
ingreso y así aumentar el valor del
capital siendo éste más capaz de
producir ingresos o quizá es utilizado
de una mejor manera así que en el futuro
podemos tener una situación en donde
tenemos un ingreso
y digamos que tenemos el mismo
rendimiento de capital del 10% r aquí es
igual al 10% también las personas dicen
bueno de lo que invierta voy a recuperar
el 10% así que en el mercado van a pagar
por estos 200 dólares
esta es una razón por la que podemos
tener un incremento en el valor de un
bien pero podemos tener otra razón para
este incremento porque tenemos cada vez
más capital y cada vez menos proyectos
en que invertir especialmente si no hay
un crecimiento en la economía así que
hay más capital que busca menos
proyectos hay menos cosas que producir
qué va a pasar en este módulo suponiendo
que esto sigue produciendo un
rendimiento del 10 por ciento el ingreso
seguirá siendo de 10 dólares quizá
alguien no tiene para pagar 100 dólares
por este bien pero quizás la siguiente
persona si pueda y viendo que va a tener
un rendimiento del 10 por ciento pues
está dispuesto incluso a pagar más por
este bien aun cuando solo tengo un
rendimiento del 9 por ciento y comprar
el bien a 101 o 102 dólares mientras más
capital tengamos a la búsqueda de este
tipo de productos o proyectos pues más
se va a incrementar el valor de este
bien lo proyecto así que el valor
200 dólares que sigue produciendo el
mismo ingreso por lo que ahora el
rendimiento va a ser de el 5% la razón
para señalar esto es que un aumento en
el valor del capital no necesariamente
significa un aumento en el rendimiento
de hecho normalmente en el mercado esto
se mueve inversamente entre sí cuando
los bonos tienen rendimientos mayores su
precio será menor y cuando los bonos son
más caros es cuando tiene el menor
rendimiento cuando vemos algo como esta
gráfica nos podría hablar más de una
acumulación de capital con cada vez
menos proyectos de inversión
especialmente si hay poco crecimiento
económico esto podría ser una historia
de acumulación de capital pero con r
disminuida disminuyendo el rendimiento
del capital y probablemente va a
convergiendo poco a poco con el
crecimiento sé
otra idea parecida a la del capital
buscar los proyectos es que las personas
tengan miedo de invertir porque les ha
ido mal en inversiones previas y ya no
quieren tomar riesgos y es por eso que
se mantiene este rendimiento del 10%
quizá con el paso del tiempo las
personas se vuelven más confiadas y
están dispuestas a invertir en proyectos
sobre negocios este es un mundo donde
las personas no toman riesgos
por lo que si quieres que invierta en mi
capital pues tendrás que darle un alto
rendimiento pero quizá en el futuro las
personas sean más tolerantes a los
riesgos
y en este mundo podemos tener algo así
las personas pueden pensar que no hagan
nada con tener el dinero guardado en el
colchón por lo que están dispuestos a
invertir su dinero aumentando este valor
y bajando el rendimiento cuando las
personas tienen miedo de invertir se les
tiene que ofrecer un rendimiento grande
para que se animen a hacerlo en cambio
en este mundo la gente no está tan
temerosa y están más dispuestos a
invertir el dinero lo cual está en línea
de que hay más capital y hay un menor
rendimiento esperado esto es consistente
con lo que vemos aquí en la gráfica ya
que este periodo de aquí es una etapa de
mucha inquietud donde tuvimos dos
guerras enormes en la historia por lo
que podemos imaginar a las personas de
esta época pues no queriendo correr
ningún riesgo escondiendo el dinero
queriendo vender sus bienes preocupados
por lo que podría pasar así que hubo
menos capital y una mayor aversión a los
riesgos sin embargo conforme pasa el
tiempo durante el periodo postguerra
personas se volvieron más tolerantes a
los riesgos ya que los recuerdos de
dichas guerras se disolvían entró más
capital al sistema si vemos épocas
anteriores como antes de la revolución
industrial o en la época medieval se
tenía poco capital y era principalmente
tierra conforme entramos a la revolución
industrial y especialmente en el siglo
20 y 21 la tierra representa cada vez
menos porcentaje del valor total del
capital ahora creamos el capital tenemos
tecnología propiedad intelectual por lo
que esto podría ser una tendencia y
nuevamente yo no tengo las respuestas a
ustedes les toca llegar a sus propias
conclusiones
esta tendencia no necesariamente implica
que estemos entrando a una nueva edad de
oro podría ser que cada vez más capital
busca proyectos en que invertir y hay
cada vez menos proyectos también podría
deberse a una menor cantidad de
rendimiento o incluso podría ser que las
personas se están volviendo más
tolerantes a los riesgos y están
dispuestos a recibir rendimientos
menores
así pues no está clara cuál es la
trayectoria y quiero dejar claro que
esto no necesariamente indica que 'la
esta gráfica a parecerse a esta de aquí
significa que estamos entrando a una
segunda edad dorada pero a ustedes les
toca decidir